nous venons comme promis sur la
situation à marie-paule ville du sud-est
de l'ukraine où le ministère russe de la
défense a lancé ce matin cessez-le-feu
pour permettre des évacuations
humanitaires
bonjour mariam piasa des bonjours film
et mario paul c'est stratégique pour
quoi c'est très stratégique et ce serait
un tournant dans cette guerre en ukraine
dans cette invasion russe si jamais les
troupes russes l'obtenait complètement
ville stratégique parce qu'elle se
trouve vous allez voir sur une carte à
la jonction entre deux territoires qui
sont déjà tenues par les forces russes
il y a à l'ouest la crimée qui a été
annexées par moscou en 2014 elle est
vous le voyez il ya le dombass
territoire où se déroule déjà la guerre
depuis 2014 entre forces loyalistes
craignent haine et forces pro-russes un
territoire qui a été reconnu comme bruce
donc il y à plus dix jours maintenant
par la douma le parlement russe donc le
contrôle de marioupol de cette ville
permettrait de réunir en fait tous ces
territoires et de faire vraiment une
bande à l'est d'avoir aussi un accès sur
la mer d'azov que vous voyez une mère
qui est pas très grande mais qui enclavé
entre la russie et l'ukraine et qui est
très importante pour l'économie créant
une chrétienne car c'est notamment par
cette route maritime que l'ukraine peut
livrer à ces céréales son acier on
estime que 20 % des exportations
ukrainiennes transitent par ce biais les
russes contrôlent déjà depuis 2014 le
détroit qui donne justement accès à
cette mer via la mer noire les russes
qui ont déjà pris les deux ports
importants à côté bernanke et carson
alors marioupol avait déjà été le
théâtre d'intenses combats en 2014 en
menant de l'annexion de la crimée
donc il y habitant marioupol c'est une
ville à majorité russophone
450 mille personnes y vivent qui résiste
pour l'instant mais qui est encerclée de
plus en plus par les forces russes si
mario paul était capturé qu'est-ce que
cela augurait de la suite alors déjà
qu'il y à un cessez le feu décidé qu'ils
aient qui effectif là par les russes ça
augure aussi peut-être d'une
intensification à des bombardements des
forces russes des combats des forces
russes contre contre cette ville le
maire demandait un cessez-le-feu pour
acheminer via un couloir humanitaire des
médicaments des vivres parce que la
ville commence à en manquer donc on l'a
appris le cessez-le-feu octroyés ça
augure un tournant en très tournant dans
cette guerre est une avancée très
significative
pour moscou merci beaucoup
mariam piasa des mots de la diplomatie